[Music]
University students on the March for
Bernie Sanders in Los Angeles showing
the enthusiasm many young people have
for the Vermont senator as a woman who
is black who is Hispanic who is clear I
believe he is the only candidate that
truly looks out for me here in the
biggest most diverse state in the u.s.
Latino voters are a crucial voting bloc
I feel like he's the only candidate who
has other Latin American countries in
mind nearly 30 percent of the state's
eligible voters are Latino and the vast
majority vote Democratic
absolutely Latinos have the power to
shape the outcomes but none of the
candidates can afford to take Latino
votes for granted direct contact is key
they need to talk in door knock and
outreach to the Latino electorate that's
important for a place like California
it's a huge robust state but you still
have to be here polls show Sanders
leading by a wide margin in California
followed by Elizabeth Warren with Joe
Biden the distant third the Sanders
campaign would like to repeat its
winning formula from Nevada last month
it put together a coalition of liberal
White's young people and Latinos polls
show three-quarters of registered Latino
voters are ready and eager to vote in
the primary with its multiple large
urban areas California is an expensive
place to campaign be a multiple high
dollar media markets right and it's a
big state right so you've got to think
about Bay Area got San Diego in LA or
separate markets so you're talking about
a lot of media spending billionaire
Michael Bloomberg saturated California
airwaves with ads but he has little to
show for it
he's only polling in the single digits
early voting has been underway in parts
of California for more than a week a big
win in the West would not give Sanders
all of the 1991 delegates he'd need to
win on the first ballot at the
Democratic convention in July but it
could provide him with a lead that the
other candidates might find almost
impossible to surmount
rob reynolds al jazeera Los Angeles